hi there place indeed Doge Doge no sorry
I don't speak Dutch
hello language enthusiasts welcome to
the line focus Channel and my name is
Paul today I'm going to talk about the
German language German is a very
important language that deserves all of
our attention it is spoken by 95 million
native speakers mainly in Central Europe
but it's also spoken by an additional 10
to 15 million second language speakers
especially in Eastern Europe it is the
majority language and an official
language in Germany of course but also
Austria Switzerland Liechtenstein and
the South Tirol region of northern Italy
it's also an official language in
Luxembourg and Belgium but it's not a
majority language there German is the
most widely spoken language in the
European Union it is also one of the
most widely taught languages in the
world with between 75 and 100 million
people having studied it as a foreign
language in both the United States and
in Europe it is the third most widely
taught foreign language did you know
that one tenth of the world's books are
published in German German is also the
second most widely used scientific
language I know some doctors and all of
them have some reading knowledge of
German because so much scientific
research is documented in German so are
you starting to get an idea of why
German is important German is a member
of the West Germanic language family
which also includes dutch afrikaans
frisian english and yiddish the West
Germanic languages are part of the wider
Germanic language family so let's take a
look at the origins of the Germanic
language family wait actually no I did
this in my last video so I'm just gonna
play that part again while I'd go get a
coffee and I'll be right back all
Germanic languages developed from
proto-germanic which was spoken around
500 BCE proto-germanic possibly
originated in Scandinavia and different
varieties of Germanic began to emerge
with migration runic inscriptions from
the 2nd century CE II show us that by
that time proto-germanic had began to
separate into distinct Western Eastern
and northern dialects oh sorry are you
guys waiting for me well let's move on
the West Germanic dialects were probably
closely related enough to be mutually
intelligible until about the 8th century
CE II but at that time something was
happening that would split the Germanic
language family and give birth to the
German language as we know it today that
was the high Germanic sound shift or the
high Germanic continental shift some
West Germanic varieties underwent a
number of sound changes nine consonants
changed to be precise and this created
two distinct groups of Germanic dialects
high german or hawk lloyd and low german
or plat voyage and just out of interest
let me pronounce these words a different
way high Deutsch and flat Deutsch hmm
maybe there's a connection with English
High German dialects arose in the
southern areas of Germany which are at a
higher elevation that's why they're
called by German the Low German dialects
existed in the northern part of Germany
at a lower elevation and also in the
Netherlands these terms do not refer to
high and low status but rather to the
elevation of the areas they were spoken
in high german can be further subdivided
into two segments upper german and
central german so what were the sound
changes that took place well let's take
a look
these consonant changes took place in
three stages in the first stage these
consonants changed intervocalic ly that
means between vowel sounds the P sound
the pup became a foe this tough sound
became sup and the cut sound became a
huh here's an example for the English
word for sleep in Low German it's sloppy
but in German it's Slaven in the second
stage these consonants changed at the
beginning of a word and also in some
other context like if they are the
second letter in a double consonant or
after an L or an R so the sound pup
became the foe like a P and an F
together the touch sound became a sub it
sounds like a TS sound even though it's
written with a Z and the cut sound
became a like a K sound followed by huh
here's an example for the English word
came in lower German its tongue but in
high german it's um in the third stage
three more consonants changed the book
sound became a paw the sound became a
toe in the gut sound became a cut
here's an example for the English word
for day in lower German its death but in
high German it's talk now all of these
sound changes took place in upper German
in the south but some of them didn't
take place in Central German and some of
them didn't take place in standard
German but we'll get to standard German
in a minute so some of you might be
thinking well how did these sounds just
switch
well they didn't instantly switch they
gradually changed over a period of a few
centuries probably between the fifth
century and 8th century see over the
centuries the dialect continuum of low
german and high german grew more and
more distinct until there were varieties
that were quite incomprehensible so
someone from the South in Bavaria would
have trouble communicating with someone
from Hamburg in the north but of course
that was before standard German the
dialects of Low German are often said to
be a separate language from high German
and they're often said to be halfway
between high German and Dutch now the
Low German dialect actually crosses the
border into the eastern part of the
Netherlands where Low German is also
spoken but these days the Low German
dialects in the north of the country are
mostly fading and basically only older
people speak them younger people might
understand them but they tend to use
standard German instead but when did
standard German come into the picture
standard German which by the way is also
called hostage in German so don't be
confused between high german and
standard german originated as a written
literary language that developed over a
few hundred years as writers tried to
write in a way that would be understood
by the largest number of people possible
from different dialect areas but perhaps
the most important factor in the
development of standard German was the
translation of the Bible into German by
Martin Luther in the year 1522 he based
his translation on the saxon dialect of
central german while including some
vocabulary from other dialects as well
virtually all speakers of German
dialects owned a copy of the new Bible
and studied it effectively popularizing
this form of written German originally
there was no single way to pronounce
this written form of German but
eventually the dialect of Hannover
became the standard for pronunciation of
standard German
standard German includes some of the
sounds of the High German consonant
aloof but not all of them because it was
influenced by the dialect of Hannover so
standard German began as a written
language but as it became the language
of Education it became more widespread
as the formal spoken language and it
also influenced the local dialects today
pretty much everyone can speak standard
German even if they speak a local
dialect casually and many local dialects
have become largely replaced by standard
German especially the low German
dialects in the north of the country but
there are still some dialects that are
quite distinct and still thriving like
the Bavarian dialect in the southeast
German is considered a plural centric
language that means that there are
multiple standard varieties of the
language there is one standard language
in Germany one in Austria and one in
Switzerland all of these standard
varieties are pretty much the same
except for some differing vocabulary but
of course those are the standard
languages Switzerland and Austria and
also South Tirol which is related to
Austria have their own dialects as well
the Austrian dialects are related to the
Bavarian dialects in southeast Germany
and the Swiss dialects are related to
the alemannic dialects in southwest
Germany maybe you saw my video about the
languages of Switzerland it's this one
right here and in that video I talked
about how the Swiss German dialects are
kind of incomprehensible to speakers of
standard German unless they also speak
an alemannic dialect from the border
area but of course that's talking about
the Swiss German dialect Swiss Germans
can speak standard German even if they
tend to use it less than people in
Germany of course they might pronounce
standard German with a different accent
but that's no big deal in Austria and
South Tyrol the situation is similar
there are dialects that might be hard to
understand for people from some other
german-speaking countries but of course
standard German is the bridge these
countries are all part of the German
sprach realm
which means the geographic area over
which that language is spoken and within
that sprach realm standard german is the
dock sprocket dr. Pratt that means the
umbrella language under which all of
those dialects can come together those
two German terms I just used sprach
realm and Doc sprockie are common
linguist
terms and I think that shows just how
much influence the German language has
over academic areas of research like
linguistics so what is the German
language like well it's closely related
to English which is obvious when we look
at the most basic sentences here's an
example I buy books often it's kalfa -
you show ich kaufe
- foucha here the word order is SVO like
in English except that the adverb comes
before the object instead of after it
here's another example with an important
twist I will buy the book today if
you've added as y2 Calvin is Veda just
oh boy - Calvin in this case we see one
of the most confusing things for
learners of German which is the
placement of the second verb at the end
of the sentence so if there's a helping
verb like will or vagine' it is in the
normal SVO position but the main verb
goes at the end another example the book
was interesting just fou violin - the
Sun das boo ba into the Sun and one more
example I like the people who work hard
each McMansion jihad a baton is mock
mention the heart a baton another thing
that learners of German find challenging
is the case system in German in German
pronouns and nouns change form depending
on their function in the sentence but
along with them the articles and
adjectives also change here's an example
of German grammatical cases using the
noun meaning table diet ich bin to death
dishes Dame tisha
G tisha D tisha there - sir Dane tution
you can see that the change takes place
not only in the noun but also in the
definite article as well the word for
table is a masculine noun in German but
there are actually three genders in
German there are masculine nouns
feminine nouns and neuter nouns and for
each of them the case forms are
different and all of these different
forms also apply to adjectives which
drives learners crazy
so while German is closely related to
English the devil is in the details even
though most of the other Germanic
languages are classified as category
one languages by the FSI German is
classified as category two it's closely
related to English and they have a lot
in common in terms of the general syntax
and vocabulary but when it comes to the
fine details of grammar there are some
challenges for learners but as always if
you are interested in german-speaking
cultures and countries or if you would
like to benefit from the widespread use
of German then don't hesitate to start
learning all challenges become
adventures when you become fascinated
the question of the day German speakers
do you think there's anything unique or
special or interesting about your local
variety of German and how do other
varieties of German sound to you let us
know in the comments down below and
everyone else jump in and let's discuss
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
you